and I felt like Norm had that space yeah
nobody perfect example right Norm's tone
was distinctive and unique like Norm's
whole world was not just me he was
making fun of you you were part of this
the suckers too yeah yeah you'd be like
I mean you're telling me you know he was
just spring you and it's that brilliant
podcast he had with Adam me again yes
yeah well I went to Norm's uh you know
his uh memorial service yeah Anatomy
gets spoke and he killed it was all
these professional experience he had him
he went up and he goes I love Norm
Macdonald even though if you Google me
today it says Holocaust denier Adam Egan
that's the first thing
and he went on about normal but it was
yeah it was perfect because the guest
didn't know that uh like half the gas no
one goal I mean I agree with you not
like this guy thinks the Holocaust
didn't happen Holocaust denier awesome
and it gets to be look you could see the
Angry Eyes like what